in the last video we use the divergence
theorem to show that the flux across
this surface right now which is equal to
the divergence of f
along or summed up in throughout the
entire region it's equal to zero and
what i want to do in this video is think
a little bit whenever you get an answer
like zero you want to think about why is
it this is saying that there's no
there's no net flux across this surface
right over here or if you sum up all of
the divergences in this volume you are
getting zero so why is that well the
simple way to think about it is when we
took the divergence of f this vector
field f is hard to visualize but the
divergence of f is fairly easy to
visualize the divergence is equal to 2
times x so over here you're going to get
as you go further and further in this
direction
as x becomes larger your divergence
becomes more and more positive so you
have very you have kind of a divergence
of two right over here you have a
divergence of one along that line and
you have a divergence of zero right
there and that's also true obviously as
you go higher because you're just
changing the z you're not changing the x
so all over here you have positive
divergence over there you have positive
adjoints and not just along that plane
but if you go in the x direction as well
this kind of this whole region of space
you have positive divergence i guess you
could say in the positive x side of r of
our octant but then as you go on that
side on the other side you have negative
divergence and this this diagram is
symmetric with respect to the z y plane
and so those divergences cancel them out
you would have had a positive flux
across the surface or positive value
right over here instead of calculating
it for this region we had calculated for
a region that was just between x's zero
and one so let's just think about that
region so that region that would been
cut off right over here
that would have been cut off right over
there and so the back i guess you could
say the back
wall of that
the back wall of this would have been
would have been the z-y plane now if we
care about this if we care about this
volume so we're essentially eliminating
the rest of it so let me try to
eliminate it as best as i can change the
colors
so if i eliminate that part of it over
there and all maybe even what we see
all of that i should have deleted that
first so if we eliminate
the back part of it and we're just
dealing with we're just dealing it with
with it when x is positive then our
entire
solution that we did in the last video
would be the exact same except now x is
going to vary between instead of
negative one and one it'll vary between
zero and one and so our bounds of
integration x is going to go between
zero and one zero and one and then in
that situation our final answer this
part this would be between zero and one
that would all be zero and we would be
left with three halves minus one half
three halves minus one half is one
minus one six which is just going to be
five six and so when you just think
about this part of it this side of it
this one that i've just drawn you had a
positive flux of 5 6 on the other side
you had a negative flux of 5 6 and then
they cancelled it out one way to
interpret that is if you think about
that entire if you if we thought about
the entire surface like what we saw in
the last video that you had an aggregate
inward flux in the last video that's why
it was negative and that is completely
offset by an outward flux right over
here the positive or you had a negative
divergence in that other region and you
have a positive divergence that
completely offsets it in this region
right over here